hey guys mkbhd here back with another
high definition video review of the
editor's keys vocal booth this is a
high-end audio isolation booth from
editor's keys that's actually portable
in a way that it can fold up and change
and adjust the way you need it to let's
take a closer look the vocal booth
itself is height adjustable and in this
video you can see i have it at about a
medium height it can extend up to about
six feet tall or down to about four and
a half feet tall this of course means
you can use it while you're either
standing or sitting either way you're
going to have the microphone you're
using on the middle on that stand part
of the vocal booth that sticks out in
between the foam rubber that does the
actual sound isolation you can see that
this top part itself is made of a very
high quality foam that's actually
corrugated so you'll get those little
dashes that dilute the sound and bounce
it all different directions and also the
back part of it is made of a very high
quality honeycombed metal and that's
definitely going to be sturdy and not
going to move while you're recording
overall if you haven't already guessed
it by now this vocal booth is something
that you're going to put your microphone
in to get the best out of the best
quality out of your microphone meaning
if it's not already noise isolating this
vocal booth will isolate the noise for
you and also going along with the theme
of portability this vocal booth by
editor's keys is also adjustable which
means you can literally just grab it and
close it up when you're done using it or
when you want to continue using it in a
specified position you can open it up a
certain amount of degrees so it's
extremely wide or you can have it at the
typical middle position that i keep it
at when i'm actually recording this
audio right now you can even swivel it
from side to side to keep it in the
optimal position for your recording and
guys you can see by the smoothness at
which it turns that it is made from high
quality materials not cheap plastic
that's not going to do the job but high
quality metal and steel and foam that's
really going to use sound isolation very
well
now something else that may or may not
be a selling point when it comes to this
vocal booth is that there is a little
bit of assembly required meaning you're
going to have to do some construction
you know pull out the manual and put
some bolts together to actually get it
standing up but once you get it stand it
up it's really going to work just fine
and it's very easy to use once you've
put the microphone inside and get to
doing some recordings in these overhead
views you'll also see that that foam
padding is pretty thick so there's no
need to worry about it not being
effective it's definitely going to do
its job and i have total confidence in
this product to do that for you so look
bottom line is if you're looking for a
very inexpensive or relatively
inexpensive way to make your current
microphone sound a lot better than it
already does i would highly recommend
the editor's keys portable vocal booth
it does its job with no real technical
hitches or anything wrong with it and
that's totally acceptable with me
overall this product gets an 8 out of 10
by mkbhd review standards for good build
quality excellent ease of use and uh
just a little bit of difficulty with
construction but that was easy to get
over so thanks for watching this video
review of mkbhd's editor's keys portable
vocal booth and we'll hopefully talk to
you guys in the next video thanks for
watching peace